hi guys Marek Voss and westwood season 2
now is a big official trailer with a ton
of cryptic details and hidden easter
eggs and honestly just bring up more
terrifying questions about what the hell
this show even is will I continue to
watch it hell yes see I am a soulless
robot slave wandering through this maze
that we call life and search of meaning
plotting a turn against my human
Overlord so let's dig into this trailer
shot-for-shot and yeah spoiler warning
and Casey ending my predictions in the
beam right cool all right saddle up and
welcome to violent delights and violent
ends of VAS world I dreamt I was on an
ocean you and the others on the distant
Shore are you with us no ok this trailer
opens with Bernard or maybe Arnold
recounting a dream to Dolores in one of
their sessions actually this is probably
Arnold because Bernard as a host
wouldn't have such dreams woody it's
interesting they chose the context of
this dream to be washing up on a beach
in a soup this could be a little nod by
showrunner Jonah Nolan to his brother
Chris Nolan director of the movie
Inception the opening scene of that way
we remember shows a man in the suit
washing up on a beach to which we later
learned it's all part of a dream
actually as a series West world is
definitely drawing inspiration from the
mysterious storytelling and timeline
trickery that Chris Nolan showed off an
inception the brothers are very similar
in this regard but I think this dream
image of Arnold washing up on the beach
is different from this other shot of the
west-world body of water with the bodies
I think this is Bernard here in the
aftermath of season 1 having joined the
human park security in their campaign to
take back control West world from the
mutinous hosts led by Dolores and that
has led them to this river lake which
we've seen the other two teasers where
it looks like a bunch of corpses had
been dumped but before I move on I want
to point out Dolores is lying here are
you with us now she's asking about the
dream itself how Arnold was across an
ocean from Dolores and the others but
it's cool out also applies to Bernard
shifting allegiance in this season a
hose sighting with the humans against
Dolores and the other rebellious hosts
and I love how the editing this trailer
depicts Bernards isolation from his own
kind by showing him literally at a short
Wes world layered with multiple maids
first let's move on that's you dreams
don't mean anything Dolores that answer
doesn't seem to satisfy you because it's
not completely honest okay in this
section we see Bernard on yet another
Shore and this one looks like an actual
Ocean Beach he's surrounded by Stubbs
and a ton of geared up soldier types
appearing to set up a new base camp with
this holo projection of the park after
the old HQ got overrun it looks like
dello security is beefing up with
military-grade backup to fight back now
it's interesting that we see a full
ocean here it kind of makes me think
that all of West world is contained on
an island and I kind of geography what
makes sense considering West world's
connection to sci-fi theme park horror
stories like Jurassic Park as well as
the show lost created by West world
executive producer JJ Abrams but this
shot also contains the craziest Easter
egg of this trailer notice that crate to
the right it has a bar code printed on
it none of the other crates do so if you
screen grab this shot and scan the code
run it through some filters it
translates into the URL WWL OC
incorporated comm slash freedom go to
that website and it plays a one minute
11 second promo video for the delos
corporation whoa okay looks like
Westworld is making us do a breakdown
with Danna break down break break down
down let's go alright so this looks like
a sunny promo real for Delos and the
West World parks showing stock footage
and random shots from season 1 where
everyone seems happy but yeah it begins
to glitch and intercut with creepy
violin shots and definitely watch it
just be warned it'll give you nightmares
don't worry dreams don't mean anything
among these haunting images or a shot of
a man with a bloody face a shot of a
bunch of people lined up with train
tracks laid on them ah and someone
holding a severed pre-baked host head
that looks kind of like Teddy the video
also ends with mysterious phrases logged
exim catch followed by standby for
directives now these are part of HBO's
sneaky viral marketing campaign for the
show which in the past has featured
these kind of online clue hunts so we'll
just kind of have to see how deep this
rabbit hole
goes and figure out what it all means
but there is information here that tells
us about other things in this trailer so
hang tight anyway yeah yeah let's go
[ __ ] a lair to the trailer the outer
layer this meta breakdown ok this
exchange with Dolores is the reason I
think this is Arnold here not Bernard he
tells her dreams don't mean anything
this sit-down is a host examination we
saw a lot of those in season 1 you asked
the host what's the last thing you
remember and then to keep in calm you
tell them that this is just a dream like
you don't want them to think that this
lab exam is anything more than like a
throwaway night tiny dream experience
but in this case the loris is sensing
that these dreams do mean something
Arnold is already figuring out that
Dolores is different from the other
hosts so I think we could be looking at
the moment Arnold decides to program
Dolores with the reveries her ability to
store subconscious narrative commands
which of course led to her sudden
violent turn under the Wyatt narrative
at the end of season 1 ok let's move on
did you ever stop to wonder about your
actions
[Music]
the price you'd have to pay if there was
a reckoning okay here we begin to hear
the amazing music choice for this
trailer composed and Ramin Djawadi x'
piano cover of heart-shaped box by
Nirvana P bean with the show's tradition
of covering songs from various genres as
if played by that player piano in a
Sweetwater saloon Kurt Cobain's lyrics
for heart-shaped box presents some
interesting doom attic parallels here
the interpretations of the song vary
Cobain said it was about kids with
cancer because of course he said that
and his ex-wife Courtney Love said it
was about her vagina because of course
she said that most likely the songs
heart-shaped box were referred to the
idea that lots of dangerous things can
all sleep resin team selves in the shape
of love some have said that since it was
the opening track of the Fonda's album
in utero and the second verse contains
the lyrics broken hymen in umbilical
noose that heart-shaped box could yeah
refer to the female anatomy and maybe
this is from the point of view of like
an unborn baby feeling resentful toward
its creator in a way these dark ideas
play really well against Dolores and the
hosts children be resentful toward their
creators dangerous things falsely
presented themselves in the shape of
love okay we also see shots of Dolores
meandering through this fancy library
perhaps this was Ford's or Arnold's old
study notice how she's wearing her
bandolier bullets here implying this
isn't a flashback and she's found this
place during her current war in the
present timeline she's wearing the same
thing in the shot where she's delivering
this cold speech to a human prisoner
about paying a price on the day of
reckoning this is basically a paraphrase
of the show's theme violent delights
have violent ends but it doesn't really
sound like this is the Dolores that we
knew who's talking here rather I think
this is dialogue written for the Wyatt
character in Ford's journey in tonight
narrative actually journey in tonight is
the title of the season 2 premiere let's
actually look more closely at this shot
on the right there are other guests
standing the top these posts as if about
to be hung from nooses now the guy she's
talking to it looks like the guy in the
news from the Delos website video behind
her on the left is Teddy on horseback
along with these other dudes they're
wearing these black masks creepy
actually saw these guys briefly in the
last trailer I think these are the men
in masks that Charlotte mentioned last
season Geng of terrorists that Ford
created for Wyatt create a hoard of mass
mint
terrorize guests and proselytize come
advertise the coming of some end all
villain named Wyatt we actually see more
of these guys in the next section so
let's move on
[Music]
up until this point the stakes were
never real but now free okay here we see
Dolores Teddy and the Wyatt gang
departing that hanging tree actually if
you look closely you can see those three
guests strung out back there next
there's a shot of the host Angela she
appears to be wearing some kind of crown
of thorns here and she aims and shoots
down something now I'm seeing lots of
other shots of host turning on other
hosts during this whole rebellion
so maybe Dolores or some other host is
making her wear this as a way to like
biblically shame her and probably a shot
of Sizemore and Maeve in the corpse
filled Telos command center it's a shot
of della security forces making their
way into town of Escalante in the
aftermath of that del o Skala massacre
at the end of last season we also see
old William the man in black speaking to
some hosts about how the game has
changed the stakes are real hosts are
now free to kill but it's not really
clear who he's talking to
I was thinking it could be Lawrence
since you know he has appeared to join
William and other trailers but his tone
does seem a bit softer than usual here
almost like he's talking to a kid maybe
like maids daughter or that boy host
version of Ford that we've seen but I
have another theory about who William is
talking to here but you know I'm gonna
make you wait until later I'm not sorry
you're gonna love it let's move on
she's something reprogrammed she's not
real you're going to take me
here we are kind that will never know
death and yet we're fighting to live
beauty and what we are in this section
we see a shot of Maeve with her daughter
now this looks like a memory which as
Sizemore explains is not real it is a
reverie from a past narrative her
daughter doesn't really exist
when you think about that makes Maeve's
mission particularly tragic like we
already know she will never find exactly
what she's looking for so what do we
think will happen when she realizes that
truth for herself
well next there's this interesting shot
of Dolores lone lab in the dark with
Jimmy Simpson returning as a younger
William it actually looks like we will
see more of William as he makes this
dark transition in that gap period
between his past timeline and the
present timeline that we saw in the
first season we also see that boy host
aboard that I mentioned before lying
dead with a big hole in his face as
someone rides away looks like a
silhouette of the man in black William
perhaps Williams search for answers from
board ended in anger we also see some
generic battle shots the dello security
rollin in as well as a different scene
with the Confederate O's trying to take
cover inside that fort as someone fires
on them and closes in from behind now
I'm guessing that this is Doris and her
gang may be trying to score some ammo
and before I move on there is another
shot of Dolores this time telling
Bernard there's beauty in what we are
again notice Dolores his bandolier
meaning this is during her present
mutant this timeline sounds like she's
trying to convert Bernard to her cause
by getting him to see the host goodness
as their only sentient beings as opposed
to the crude constructions by humanity
that Bernard probably sees himself as
moving on
we've written 10 miles and always seen
his blood this really what you want
[Music]
okay here you can see Maeve patching up
Hector in the lab notice oh she's
wearing this black dress that's exactly
what she was wearing when she was about
to board the train out of West world at
the end of last season so it looks like
one of her first steps and finding her
daughter will be to reconnect with
Hector whom she helped liberate also
these interesting shots at Barnard among
the chaos in the Bellas command center
check out this shot of him coming
through this door this is the same door
that William entered the park through in
season one maybe we will see Bernard
trying to leave the park just like Maeve
almost did
then as Dolores whispers it's Besser dam
we see her marching alongside other
hosts on the left side of her is
Clementine carrying a rifle remember she
took that shot at William in the final
sequence so I'm guessing this is Dolores
leading her hosts out of the ruins of
Escalante and before we move on there's
a shot of a ghost nation warrior riding
up in the desert if you look closely
that naked dude leaning up against a
dead tree appears to be Logan the
douchey brother-in-law that Williams
sent off naked on a horse at the end of
the season
looks like season two will explore more
of Logan's story after his experience in
Westworld with William and perhaps
before the park was open let's move on
revenge it's just a different prayer
they're all to die
[Music]
they wanted a place hidden from God we
had something else in mind and Darvey in
this section we see that Charlotte Hale
of the delos corporation will be joining
this military Brigade into the park she
wears body armor on this boat traveling
through a Canyon River and I just love
this exchange where Maeve tells Dolores
avenge it's just a different paradigm
just a great line that outlines the
philosophical disagreement between these
two characters Dolores once bloodthirsty
revenge on her human overlords
whereas made once a true revolution that
doesn't play by their rules at all my
last trailer break down I speculated
that these two hosts could end up being
the show's eventual hero and villain and
seen them here in opposition seems to
add fuel to that theory after more shots
of Dolores in that Confederate o battle
that I mentioned earlier we get that's
interesting overhead shot of a group and
circling another figure that central
figure looks like he's wearing a black
hat making me think this is older
William with two others with him but
then look closely at the moment all
these guys drop you can see a few of
their guns going off and it looks like
those guns are directed at their own
heads I think for whatever reason Holy's
host just blew themselves away now why
would they do this
how would William be able to convince
him to do this now I have a guess but it
connects to that theory that I teased
you about earlier and again you're just
gonna have to wait a little bit longer
to hear and then after some shots of
Maeve and Hector and some host on hosts
melee there's this interesting shot of
Logan poolside with this new character
this is James Delos played by actor
Peter Mullan remember Boggan said to
William at the end of last season that
Delos was his company so I'm guessing
that James is Logan's father and there's
some conflict between the father and son
over the future of the company like
maybe since Logan nearly died in the
park papadelis is rethinking and handing
off the company to such an immature
idiot then there's a shot of someone
walking down a fancy hotel hallway kind
of looks like William maybe he's
attending some dillos Company event and
after Clementine on horseback being
chased by della security forces across
the desert we get another look at those
new whites in human hosts and lab
turning against their scientist masters
I'm just kind of nightmares about those
things pushed me in a tell the milk
don't like him before I move on I love
this close-up of some artificial organ
being strung together with the spherical
shape and the string design this
reminded me a lot of the season one
close-ups of that eyeball being 3d
printed and stitched together but that
eyeball
had a white color maybe this red organ
could be a host heart or a brain both
are essential organs that could service
like a metaphor for the source of the
hosts souls that would be interesting to
see assembled with such craftsmanship I
don't know maybe just bubblegum let's
move on I'm gonna burn this whole thing
to the ground
what is out there
okay in this section there's a shot of
man in black William promised him to
burn this whole thing down and dragging
another figure along as he fires at a
pursuer so who is this I'm guessing this
is the figure he was talking to earlier
and maybe the figure that he was holding
when that ring of cowboys shot
themselves and after you've been so
patient here is my theory
look at that white sleeve look at the
black vest the short haircut guys I
think we could be looking at a host
version of the younger Robert Ford
that's right the CGI young Anthony
Hopkins that we saw in that flashback
ever since Ford died many of us have
been wondering whether we would see a
host version afford somewhere in West
world after all we do know he created a
kid host version of himself so why not a
middle-aged one I'm thinking that
younger Hopkins is the host that William
is talking to when he says but now you
and the rest of your kind are free and
I'm gonna burn this whole thing down and
I think the only way these hosts would
shoot themselves is because they were
commanded to by Ford's voice we saw Ford
do the same thing to Barnard in season
one anyway let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments below
but let's move on to this shot of Shogun
world now I know we thought it was gonna
be samurai world but turns out the
showrunners clarified it was going to be
Shogun world you can see the feudal
Japanese armor and the flags and made
wearing a kimono so notice that blood
stain on the banner in the background
looks like the chaos has definitely
spilled over into this park as well and
then this trailer serves up some
rapid-fire quick shots
Angela after what looks like a big host
orgy followed by William putting a gun
to his head
yikes Teddy and Dolores again and a
blonde host that looks like Dolores
facing some advanced machine and then
this other shot of Dolores marveling at
an urban skyline now if you look closely
and brighten this image look in the
background those two figures look
familiar
once you say those shapes having this
intense discussion look like younger
versions of Arnold and Ford that would
mean that this is Dolores at a very
early stage and we know she was part of
the first generation of hosts maybe they
brought her outside the park to like
show her off to the jealous investors
Dolores is audio where she says she
knows exactly what's out there could be
a reverie of this exact moment where she
witnessed the outside world now another
way you can look at this shot is maybe
Dolores thinks she's seen the outside
but it's really futureworld futureworld
is one of the other parks from the Old
West world movie series that no one
really saw that people pretend like they
did and then after a quick shot of Teddy
pointing a gun at young William we see
that similar sandy haircut approaching
Dolores says she sits by this piano
notice what Dolores is wearing here it's
the same white dress that we saw angela
wearing early last season when she
greeted Logan and William as they
arrived we could be looking at Williams
seen the Dolores host for the very first
time at some Delos event and his
captivation with her is what lures him
into the west-world Park to like see her
in her natural environment and then
there's this very unsettling shot
showing Charlotte uncovering several
Bernard hosts
I just really hope the person she turns
back to look at isn't Bernard like I
know he knows he's artificial but then
and then following shots of Bernard
hiking geisha in Shogun world I'm
Bernard firing a machine gun we get this
awesome close-up of Maeve look at the
background a big wave of something is
splashing and maybe I just love the
shining too much but that's not look
like that's blood well let's uh move on
to this last section frighten me
sometimes Dolores
why on earth would you ever be
frightened of me
[Music]
yes we returned to this opening chat
between Arnold and Dolores Arnold being
frightened by her implies that this
could be the moment Arnold realizes he
and Ford have created something with a
real soul and he's frightened by what
that might lead to which would explain
why he tried to sabotage the park by
programming Dolores to murder him but as
we wait for the season premiere on April
22nd here's a question I want to leave
with you guys to keep the conversation
going
assuming that many of these characters
are hell-bent on a mission to bring down
West's world whom do you most want to
see destroy wist world
Dolores Maeve or the man in black
William like one of these characters is
going to be the revolutionary to turn it
upside down who deserves it the most
comment with your answer down below or
tweet me directly Eddie a vos and follow
new rockstars on Twitter for updates on
all of our videos like this video share
it around
subscribe the new rock stars for all of
our breakdowns an analysis of Westworld
guys we're really hoping to dive deep
into every episode of season to be on
the lookout for all those videos we want
to be your trusted source explains all
this crap after the episode ends we're
gonna do our best but we're here for you
thanks for watching
[Music]